MINZAYAR OO: Some work by day.
Some work by night, jumping
and running along steep slopes,
or moving among the arms and
legs of big mining machines,
and with landslides often
killing hundreds of them
at a time.
INTERVIEWER: This is the world's
epicenter of jade mining--
in the town of Hpakant
in Northern Myanmar.
It's here where large
mining companies
use dynamite to turn
mountains into rubble, where
impoverished
freelance miners then
rush to scavenge through debris
without any safety measures,
hoping to find the coveted
milky green gemstone.
MINZAYAR OO: For the Chinese,
they love the jade stones.
There's even a saying, gold is
valuable but jade is priceless.
It is a status of wealth.
It is a symbol of charm, good
luck, good health, et cetera.
A handful, a small size
of a good quality stone
can be worth up to
millions of dollars.
INTERVIEWER: That was Minzayar
Oo, a photojournalist who
has been documenting the
harsh and complex realities
surrounding this precious stone.
MINZAYAR OO: In my
opinion, this dream,
which is to find a
life changing stone,
seems really a rare
chance compared
to the higher chance of
being killed in an accident
or to becoming drug
addicts, or maybe worse.
INTERVIEWER: In
2015, a landslide
collapsed on a mining camp,
burying 114 sleeping workers.
But despite the risk of
death and backbreaking work,
the miners are still pouring in.
Myanmar's jade mining industry
is worth up to $31 billion
per year, nearly half
of the national GDP.
But most of this
wealth gets pocketed
by large companies, drug
lords, and the military elite.
MINZAYAR OO: The jade mining
here also linked in many ways
to the longest civil
conflict in the country.
At the same time, it
has also been fueling
the conflict, the drug trade.
It has played a big role in
countless human rights abuses
in the region.
INTERVIEWER: However,
this tide could change.
In 2016, Myanmar elected
its first civilian president
after 50 years of military rule.
And it seems the government
is making strides
to fight corruption and improve
conditions for jade miners.
In part, it's thanks
to photojournalists
like Minzayar Oo
whose work shows
that sometimes luxury comes
with a dark and hidden price.
MINZAYAR OO: I hope that my
work highlights the human costs,
and that it would raise a
question if that cost is
really worth it after all.
INTERVIEWER: Don't forget
to subscribe for more Seeker
Stories, and click here to
see how women in Afghanistan
are finding their
voice behind the burka.